what's going on guys this is rob and uh
i guess it's kind of good that we didn't
have a chance to do episode two last
week because nothing happened so quick
review miss marvel episode two uh so
stuff happened whatever nothing really
mattered and then cool okay so episode
number three
let's talk about episode three right
this was cool and this actually gave us
it gave us a lot of information but no
real information at the same time and
the reason why is because
the mcu is drastically changing things
and again it makes sense right i mean
for the last little while the mcu has
just kind of been taking stuff from
marvel comics and reworking it in their
own way they've been doing that for a
while but it seems like they're doing it
a lot more intensely now than they have
before it's not an inherently bad thing
and honestly i think it's cool like i
always say i've been reading mobile
comics for a long time so i don't really
want to see like the actual marvel comic
story perfectly adapted to like a film
or tv show because i've seen all that
before it wouldn't really be interesting
but to shift it up and change it around
i think is a cool thing and miss
marvel's doing that in a drastic way so
one of the things and really kind of the
big thing that episode three gave us was
a little bit of backstory and so far
that there are two bracelets that exist
out there or at least that seems to be
the case that kamala khan basically has
the second bracelet and that using them
together the gen would seemingly be able
to get back to their own universe or
their own dimension or possibly even
expand their sphere of influence in the
the main world you know the main earth
itself right in the the earth 616
reality if you want to call it that but
this idea of the gin and the clandestine
is pretty cool now one of the things i
want to specify here is that it's not
clandestine it is the clandestine right
they're two separate two separate words
at least that's how it is in marvel
comics they're obviously changing it in
a pretty drastic way the gen are pretty
self-explanatory there's not a whole lot
to go on there which i think is one of
the reasons why the marvel cinematic
universe chose to go with that idea
because they can literally just kind of
rework this in any way they want because
it is a really obscure thing technically
speaking the jinn first appeared in
marvel comics in young allies number
seven back in 1943 but that was when
marvel comics was timely comics so those
who don't really know that that history
kind of a quick 30 second explanation
here the way you had it when you
initially had like joe simon and jack
kirby who created captain america you
had the original appearance of namor the
submariner back then it was just timely
comics and they only formed because of
the success of dc comics and all
american comics with like superman
wonder woman the flash green lantern
things like that and so timely was
basically the precursor to marvel
delving into comics for the very first
time after superheroes stopped being
popular timely comics became atlas
comics and focused on science fiction
stories but when superheroes became
popular again in the 1950s due to dc
showcase number four and the
introduction of the flash atlas comics
became marvel comics technically stan
lee started back when it was atlas but
he was the one that basically led the
charge in atlas becoming marvel and
creating or bringing back a lot of the
superheroes that we know today so the
idea of the gen first appearing was back
when it was timely comics just one of
those attempts by the early like super
early version of marvel to delve into
you know comic books themselves and it
was okay the most commonly cited true
appearance of the gin in marvel comics
comes in marvel comics presents number
158 in 1994 and this basically dealt
with the clandestine and it dealt with
adam and it dealt with ellie alf i think
is how you i could never pronounce her
name correctly i never have i've never
been able to pronounce her name right 20
some odd years and i always get it wrong
the general gist of this is that adam
was a guy who lived in a town called
ravenscroft there eventually came a
point where he encountered this crazy
wizard he basically overpowered this guy
the wizard had a gen gym with him and
then ultimately the gym was destroyed by
adam and when that happened it freed uh
elial
it freed the chick basically the gin and
the result was that she resurrected or
at least restored adam and then gave him
immortality and invulnerability and the
two of them just started banging and so
they basically created the clandestine
that's kind of where that whole thing
comes from now obviously that story is
not going to apply to miss marvel that
what they're doing and i think it's cool
that they're doing that what they're
doing is they're likely going to take
that story and they're going to rework
it for miss marvel's heritage and her
culture which again i think is a cool
thing because for most of you guys out
there who are probably going to complain
if i had never explained to you what the
clandestine was you probably wouldn't
know so the thing about this is that uh
it it creates this really interesting
idea
of of creating a kind of history unique
to her right it's very specific to her
and so i i love the i love that concept
now the gin themselves i mean they're
murky at best right like every once in a
while they show up and they do some
stuff but their history and form and
function is exactly what you think it is
right that like if a person owns the
name of the genie itself in the sense
like if you want to apply it to a really
rudimentary concept a genie in a lamp
and a person discovers the lamp they rub
the lamp and the genie comes out that
genie is now bound to that person more
often than not it fits the idea that the
genie are inherently evil i don't know
that's actually true as i understand the
real world mythos to a degree which is
kind of what marvel based it on that the
history of the genie is that it is an
actual evil creature i don't know that's
true or not i'm not i'm not going to
swear to that but the the thing about
this is they're just kind of murky the
reality here is that the only real link
to the clandestine and the gin
themselves
is basically the clandestine the fact
that adam is with a gin and their
offspring are basically a combination of
both gin and normal human so that's
really the only only link you get there
if i were a betting man i would say
they're using a combination of things
they're you know if you're talking about
alternate dimensions and things like
that they're rolling that into the mix
they're probably using the idea of the
of the neofim and the chiarafem and
they're combining that with the
clandestine and the gin and that's
basically it the the chaff and the rfm
they are technically mutants albeit very
early precursor two mutants so really
more proto-mutants than anything else
but it's literally angels and demons as
they were viewed by humanity in the
early days because there was a point
when the war between the two took place
in the earthly dimension and people
thought it was angels and demons
fighting each other just because of how
they look but they do have their own
dimensions right the brimstone dimension
is where the uh where the nail film are
from and heaven or what passes for
heaven in marvel comics is where the
chaorifim are from but like they have
their own individual dimensions in their
own individual realms places where they
operate from and really that depiction
is designed to quite literally at least
the way chuck austin did it back in the
day is designed to quite literally show
the war between angels and demons in
marvel comics nightcrawler for example
is the son of azazel and azazel is a
nayafim technically nightcrawler is too
whenever he teleports he teleports
through the brimstone dimension and to
wherever his destination is going to be
now i don't think that the miss marvel
show is taking that exact adaptation and
applying it here i don't think the gen
are like mutants i don't think like the
clandestine or mutants i think it's more
of something i can those you guys who
saw a daredevil like the cast versus the
hand that kind of a thing right like
just two competing organizations one
representing evil one representing good
and then marvel's applying that to the
miss marvel mythos and just kind of
going from there either way i think it's
cool i was a little on the fence when
they were showing like what her new
level of power was or her new type of
power not gonna lie i was really kind of
hoping it was tied down to the nega
bands and the quantum bands don't
necessarily know if that's still the
case maybe it's just a reworked mythos
again i'm not 100 sure that the marvel
cinematic universe is going to go in the
direction of a giant all-seeing eye
that's attached to basically a floating
swamp creating some mystical bands right
the quantum bands that just get applied
to whoever it is that's wielding them
but one of the things to know and it's a
question that doesn't seem like it's
fully been answered or perhaps i missed
something i don't think the bands
themselves were created by like the gin
or the clandestine i think they just
stumbled across them as a means to
return back to their dimension just a
mode of transportation so it may be one
of those things where the actual origin
of those bands is still mystic in nature
or there's still uh still a mystery
right we still don't know exactly what's
going on there again i may have missed
something there and if i did i'm sure
you guys will correct me but i don't
think they explicitly stated that the
bands were created by the gen or the
clandestine which still leaves their
origin ambiguous so there's still a lot
that they can do with that but
regardless i do like the idea that miss
marvel is not just some inhuman who is
exposed to the terrorist and miss and
now she has powers and that's it i like
that they're actually building it up now
a lot of that's because for me i do
prefer stories that deal with alternate
realities alternate dimensions things
like that so it just resonates better
with me on a more personal level i know
that there i know people out there like
there's like five people out there who
love the inhumans right they're like
five inhuman fans in the whole world
which makes sense because the inhumans
suck so i was never really a huge fan of
the idea that like she was inhuman
although they you know those five folks
may absolutely love that idea but the
thing about it is i i love the direction
that the show is going in it's obvious
again watching the show it's not your
typical marvel audience and in fact this
is something that i saw in a reddit post
like the three times a year that i do
browse that just cesspool of a website
and somebody had mentioned that marvel's
no longer going in the direction where
it's one thing for everybody but
creating something for everyone which
does have its benefits and its drawbacks
right if you look at loki for example
loki was kind of the the last bit of
that right kind of the last vestige loki
one division was kind of last vestiges
of here's a general show that's targeted
towards everybody who's a fan of the mcu
miss marvel is one of the first real
outings and really even including shang
chi where they launch a product that is
geared towards a particular target
audience but is accessible by everybody
which i think is kind of a cool thing i
like that they're doing it that here and
you feel it in the show right this show
you can tell would resonate far more
intensely with a person who is pakistani
but a person who is muslim especially a
young pakistani woman who comes from a
traditional family that's the target
audience right there like that's that's
your target audience or maybe just
teenagers in general like coming of age
stories because bruno is not a pakistani
guy he's just a white kid so i mean it
is one of those things where it kind of
hits in different ways but i do love
what they're doing with the show and i
do like the idea they're invoking this
kind of mysticism this idea of alternate
beings and so on and so forth but i'm
curious where they're going with it
because there was a part of me as i was
watching this and they were talking you
know she was talking about the idea of
the gin and that kind of stuff and it
was like it feels like to a degree
they're kind of reworking the original
origin of america chavez and applying it
here but then i realized that they
already did that a bit with america
chavez and doctor strange too so
obviously they're just taking two
obscure concepts in marvel and applying
it to miss marvel and then reworking
them to fit her landscape again i think
it's cool right i think it's a it's a
it's a cool concept i mean again i
imagine there are some people are going
to be upset about it right but i mean
why are you upset about something you
know nothing about because you probably
didn't know anything about the
clandestine you had to look it up
wait something they changed that i knew
nothing about that's a problem why can't
they keep the things that i have no
understanding about the way they are i
mean it's kind of weird because you
don't you don't know that they're
changing it you'd have to look it up to
find out they are but nonetheless well
it's just one of those those interesting
concepts right i like what they're doing
with the with this show i think it's a
cool show having said that
to a degree and episode number three
really kind of shows it some of the
themes are kind of wearing thin and that
was one of the issues that i had with
the original miss marvel concept or
comic by g willa wilson is after a while
the interpersonal struggles between
kamala khan and her mom it's like okay
how long is this gonna go on for right
like i mean just
say something right like that they kind
of seem to be just just holding on to
that as long as they possibly can and
obviously they are it'll likely be the
end of the show when she finally reveals
everything to her family or it's going
to be some major event when like it
turns out her mom is a person with
magical abilities that kind of a thing
something will happen in that capacity
where they'll have some sort of
relatable concept and that'll basically
be it right it'll be the way they come
to terms with each other but that that
kind of thing sort of gets me to a
little bit but at the same time i'm 39
years old right i'm not some 16 year old
girl you know who's trying to find her
place in the world and pushing
boundaries with her mom and dad and they
want to be able to do their own thing
but they also want to have their safe
space at the same time where they want
they they want all the freedom of
adulthood with none of the
responsibilities
you know i'm not i'm not that person not
anymore you know so that doesn't
necessarily uh you know really relate to
me and kind of gets a little bit
annoying but for the most part i'm
excited to see where they go i think
this episode was much better than
episode two episode two felt like filler
it felt unnecessary it felt like there
was no real development there it just
literally felt like they were killing
time i kind of understand why they gave
us that because with everything that
happened in episode one it'd be hard to
incorporate the elements of episode two
into episode one and create an hour-long
show or an hour-long episode of just be
a little too much but episode 2 felt
unnecessary but we're halfway through so
i'm curious to see what happens over the
next few episodes of the show itself so
with that being said guys let me know
what you think down in the in the the
comments section right i mean do you are
you feeling the whole idea of the gin
and the clandestine let me know what you
guys think thank you all for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace